françois bellefeuille et un des premiers
humoristes québécois à avoir récemment
grossi les rangs de netflix
je peux pas dire non à netflix parce que
pour moi j'étais un amateur de stand-up
en premier netflix et la place pour
aller voir de l'humour en anglais en
effet depuis plusieurs années déjà
netflix diffuse une quantité importante
de spectacle américain et le géant mise
gros sur l'humour
l'entreprise aurait offert près de 60
millions de dollars américains à dave
chappelle netflix recrute maintenant au
québec ça ne fait que nous stimuler à
nous déployer
alors les gens vont pause s'abreuver
d'humour québécois sur notre liste ision
accès peut-être que des formes
auxquelles on pourrait penser maintenant
je viens d'où ça va être vraiment faussé
au total netflix a fait appel à quatre
humoristes québécois pour sa série
humoristes du monde qui présente des
artistes de plusieurs pays
une série de qualité mais attention dit
certains bienvenue en france c'est une
belle campagne de communication et de
notoriété pour eux au québec et les
gestes qu'ils posent présentement on en
fait une grande histoire mais en rien
nouveau les télédiffuseurs québécois
comme tva comme radio canada et aux
investissements la création au québec
depuis de nombreuses années et ils ont
participé eux au développement de la
culture québécoise ils sont nombreux à
applaudir l'ajout de contenu canadien
sur netflix mais le géant ne doit pas
devenir à long terme le seul grand
diffuseur de contenu québécois
selon jacques k primo si on encourage
que netflix devient finalement anglais
le polyvalent diffuseur qu'il juge tout
on va voir mourir nos deux sujets locaux
qu'ils ont sont vraiment à la chose la
production la peur c'est le contraire de
l'audace de passage à montréal la
ministre de la culture fait aussi une
mise en garde dans le dossier netflix
il faut pas cannibaliser notre propre
industrie tout citoyen qui nous écoutent
qui travaillent qui a des revenus et qui
paie ses impôts ici est frustré de voir
qu'une entreprise qui fait des revenus
ici
ne pète pas les impôts ici sont déjà en
partant ça ne choque françois
bellefeuille n'a que de bons mots pour
netflix lui qui dirait oui à une
carrière en anglais la guerre est lancée
moi je fais je disais que comme artiste
neflix montrait très bien traités je
suis sentie du respect bien payé mon
fils tu te prends pas l'ange de deux
habitués du rock humaine soudan sont
sévères
ici louis philippe ouimet radio canada
montréal